Michael Bay's Transformers films always
more than met the eye a lot more like so
much more that sometimes had no clue
what was going on right of the Beast had
one specific thing to fix that for years
the Transformers movie franchise was
synonymous with director Michael Bay the
first five films exemplified what would
be referred to as Mayhem complete with
explosions sophomore humor and
nonsensical plots
one drugs
given the financial success of these
movies it's hard to argue with the
results even if many of these films
particularly the four sequels building
off 2007's Transformers were received
well by critics 2018's bumblebee
represented a Fresh Step for the series
earning a franchise best Rotten Tomatoes
score of 91 from professional reviewers
in a way Transformers rise of the beast
that's the difference between these two
ascetics it has a bit more bombastic
action going for it reminiscent of the
Michael Bay films but it maintains more
of an emotional core that helped make
bumblebee stand out and while there's
plenty of action it's hard not to
recognize one major improvement over the
bay verse namely that you can actually
make out what's happening during the
fight the fights in the Transformers
movies tend to be a lot of Sound and
Fury signifying nothing but rise of the
Beast wisely takes steps in the right
direction to make these sequences
resonate given how Michael Bay is so
closely affiliated with explosions and
over-the-top fight scenes it's a bit
weird that so many of the fights in his
Transformers movies are barely legible
given the muted color palettes of both
Autobots and Decepticons as well as the
conflicts taking place in cities a lot
of the time it tends to look like metal
clashing against metal when a battle
actually does end it can take a second
to figure out if an Autobots or
decepticon emerged Victorious this
problem only exacerbated as the sequels
went on with each fight getting uglier
than the last however rise of the Beast
takes a smart approach to ensure
audiences can follow the action
especially when it comes to the final
climactic battle this particular fight
occurs amidst a Barren backdrop some
viewers may not like having such a dull
Battleground but in this instance it
actually works for the film's advantage
with all the gray in the background it's
easier to make out the combatants one
can follow the action and determine
who's fighting here granted the effects
technology is more advanced now than it
was in the 2000s and 2010s which
inevitably aided with such fights anyway
but the decision to forego once on
destruction in a city for something
that's admittedly a bit duller helps
make it easier to distinguish characters
and fights I'm not the one to fear Prime
there is a Darkness coming
live-action adaptations of cartoons in
the 2000s and 2010s had a bad habit of
over complicating what should have been
simple designs the Transformers and
Michael Bay's movies have a lot going on
a problem extending into another Bay
involved series Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles while these designs may have
been justified by claiming there's
greater realism people ultimately want
to see something that reminds them of
the cartoons they loved as a child a big
selling point of 2018's bumblebees that
the titular character as well as other
Autobots that designs that more closely
resembled their cartoon counterparts
they were cleaner and simpler and the
rise of the Beast wisely follows this
direction the new movie opts for more
basic designs on top of having brighter
color palettes so when Optimus Prime
fights the Buddies you can clearly see
the Autobots signature red and blue
color palette contrasted against the
often gray villains it's interesting how
over the top the Michael Bay movies were
and how subsequent spin-offs and
prequels have opted for a lesser's more
approach inevitably some may miss the
bahim of these films but feeling like
you understood the action scene as it
was happening might be the better
approach to the franchise
[Music]